luffy will be one of the strongest and
most influential characters in one piece
at the end of wano throughout this arc
he has pushed his hockey abilities to a
whole new level now being able to use
advanced forms of all three types he's
capable to look slightly into the future
after his fight with katakuri is able to
deal immense damage to enemies from the
inside by circulating his armament haki
in preparation for the raid on
onygashima and now has unlocked the true
powers of conqueror's haki during his
fight with kaido manifesting it into the
ultimate physical force that can be used
to make yourself close to indestructible
and break through any defense
by taking these three skills to the next
level the yonko level i guess luffy has
already proven that he has the right
ambitions needed to stand at the top and
become king of the pirates but is haki
really the only thing that luffy will
need to improve to claim that title and
find the one piece i think not luffy has
shown that he can fight on a level with
kaido and big mom right now which don't
get me wrong already shows just how
ridiculously much luffy has grown just
since the beginning of wano but don't
forget that kaido also had to face off
against the scabbards and three others
of the supernova before getting into the
one versus one deal with luffy
[Applause]
and even then when he starts taking more
and more actual damage throughout the
fight still luffy seems to be the one
closer to running out of energy first
and yet as we all know luffy has to win
and so it was clear to the beginning i
think that luffy would also need to get
an upgrade to his devil fruit power
abilities as well once the raid on
onygashima started a lot has been thrown
out there gear 5 the gomu gomonomi
finally awakening or i personally always
thought that that was the most
fascinating option luffy actually not
being a rubber man altogether but having
eaten a legendary devil fruit all along
so let's talk about it what's up my name
is manu and since quite early on wano
has already been my favorite arc in all
of one piece with the exception of water
7. i believe the detail in which ichiro
oda the author of one piece has painted
the rich culture and history of wano in
the first two acts is truly unparalleled
in the story before this wano clearly
was always going to be a passion project
and pivotal moment in the story for this
man that was planned right from the
start odin's flashback that was a truly
unexpected firework of reveals and
epicness to me personally was the best
in the story so far rivaled again only
by robins and the character development
so many of our favorite characters have
went through in the land of the samurai
is just unparalleled with countless arcs
culminating here i'm talking sanji law
big mom momo and basically the entire
saga ever since entering the new world
and still despite my love for great
storytelling and world building
still once the fighting actually began
even i couldn't help but think about
this one thing how strong is luffy going
to be at the end of all this and going
into the next arc i think by now there
is a pretty clear answer to this but
what you need to understand is that
luffy's influence in the world doesn't
just come purely from him becoming
stronger but also from who he is as a
person
as mihawk explains wonderfully here
luffy has the very unique and powerful
ability to slowly pull the people around
him towards him friends and enemies
alike and mihawk clearly someone who
knows what he's talking about because he
is incredibly powerful himself so when
he says that it's luffy's most
terrifying power i feel like we should
take that quite seriously also i just
find it really hard not to respect what
this man has to say so how exactly has
luffy risen to the position in the world
where he's at right now where he's
respected by yonko and a number one
target for the world government well
easy he has already changed the entire
balance of the world fundamentally he
defeated three of them crocodile
doflamingo and moria getting stronger
and stronger in the process and hancock
kuma mihawk law and i guess even buggy
have helped him at some point with
jimbei even joining his crew
and by exposing their plots on alabast
and drathrosa he then even pulled
submarines on his side including
fujitora who ended up being the decisive
force in getting rid of the system
altogether shifting the balance of the
three powers in the world significantly
that had probably been established for
ages
even more impressively to me he is as
far as we know at least the first pirate
since rox to openly declare war on the
world government when saving robin from
anna's lobby he punched a celestial
dragon on zabaodi broke into impel down
the most safe prison in the world and
disrupted the war at marineford to save
his brother ace
which i absolutely love because even
though the government technically won
yes luffy managed to completely ruin
their intended victory over piracy by
gaining a ton of allies unlocking
congress hockey revealing his true
heritage and even inspiring whitebeard
to repeat roger's last words making the
pirate movement probably even stronger
than before
and now after having awakened his hockey
powers after two years of training luffy
is doing the same thing all over again
but this time with the yonko system he
formed powerful alliances to take down
kaido embarrassed big mom in front of
the entire world forced both of them to
form an alliance on their own and still
had the audacity to attack them heads on
in their own territory and i'm not even
talking about shanks yet who most likely
has been a powerful ally to luffy behind
the scenes all the while if oda sensei
doesn't pull the world's largest reverse
card move on all of us and on top of all
that he's also allied to other former
members of the roger pirates like raley
[Applause]
[Music]
he has ties to the revolutionary army
because yeah his dead and is friends
with ancient weapons like shirahoshi
basically whatever world-changing event
there has been in the story so far luffy
has been somehow involved in it and
after wano having survived and overcome
the alliance of two of the yonko he also
is in possession of more road pony
glyphs than anyone else at this point
with someone in his crew actually
capable of reading them and leading him
to the one piece
i think it's pretty fair to assume that
luffy after wano is pretty much the most
wanted and influential person on the sea
rivaled only by blackbeard and his
father dragon in terms of the threat
that he poses to the world government so
why do i think that luffy massively
improving his hockey was still not
enough for wano well to answer that
spicy question i need something to calm
my nerves first and what a coincidence
because this video has the perfect
sponsor for just that boxu who sent me
their wonderful sakura season edition
this month baksu is a monthly snack box
subscription service that delivers
original assortments of premium japanese
snacks and tea pairings directly from
japan to wherever you may live for me
the best thing about this besides how
good all this stuff actually tastes is
that they collaborate with traditional
japanese family manufacturers that make
these snacks and candies locally so you
don't just get some random stuff you can
just get in any japanese supermarket but
quality products so this is the perfect
opportunity to experience some great
authentic japanese food if you want to
try it out for yourself go get your own
box with snack box and get 15 bucks of
your first order using my code and link
in the description below now just as
many other people i'm pretty sure that
there will be at least one more arc
before love tale with elbaf and who
knows knowing oda sensei maybe even one
or two other smaller ones so couldn't
luffy simply have gotten a power-up in
those arcs as well well i think the
story has always suggested to us that no
luffy will have to get at least one more
power upgrade during wano
i honestly believe that his
long-anticipated encounter with shanks
will center around truly mastering his
conquest hockey and proving himself as
worthy to finding the one piece but i
don't think that he will unlock any new
skills during that necessarily as i've
discussed in detail in this video here i
believe that luffy zorro and who knows
maybe even sanji will be out for the
first half of the alberth arc of the
wano if it is the albert arc of course
all of them having gone far beyond their
limits and exhausting their powers well
this might well be an arc for characters
like usopp to shine before the final
battle against blackbeard so even if
luffy will have to reach his true peak
against his strongest opponent on
lovetail i think the groundworks for all
of that will have to be have laid in
wano and so the next crazy power he
needs to defeat teach can't just be
pulled out of nowhere but something
we've seen before just not fully
controlled or perfected yet at that
point and this power of course is
related to his devil fruit something i
actually already made an entire series
of videos about i've really found it
interesting to follow how the focus for
luffy's powers has shifted throughout
his fight with kaido
at first he was beaten real badly when
arriving at wano so he learned rio to be
able to deal at least some damage to
kaido and even though that worked a lot
better he still needed the support of
law kid and killer and zorro of course
then luffy finally understood that he
could actively use his congress hockey
to fight kaido one on one as rayleigh
explains
and luffy's hockey truly bloomed during
this battle as much as it could i would
argue truly bringing him into yonko
territory power wise by the way i will
make a video analyzing and explaining
hockey in one piece soon so if you want
to see that and are a true mad lad make
sure to subscribe and become one of five
hundred thousand five hundred thousand
yeah people who are subscribed to this
channel for some reason thank you and
yet even that still wasn't enough so the
only thing left that luffy had neglected
throughout the new world pretty much
that gave all the other yonko an even
bigger advantage was the use of their
powerful devil fruits and that's when
the focus of the story once again had to
shift
now i want you to be careful because
there will be manga spoilers from hero
mouths so suddenly we learned about
shanks going out of his way to steal the
gomugo monomi which as i explained in
this video that wow many of you really
liked clearly suggested that the fruit
might be very special indeed we learn
about the sun god mika that
coincidentally just literally looks like
luffy silhouette on skypea it's revealed
that even law and kit have already
managed to awaken their fruits and
finally we learned that the gorosei
think that a legendary devil fruit will
awaken once again which true name has
been hidden from history and they order
luffy to be taken out by zp0 apparently
putting a premature and quite
unhonorable end to luffy's duel with
kaido
and so based on all of this i personally
feel like the manga has basically been
screaming for luffy to awaken new powers
in this situation for quite a while now
and there are really only three valid
options to consider here one luffy finds
a new creative and powerful way to use
his current flute
he unlocks his current flute his current
throat and unlocks gear 5. two luffy
awakens his rubber fruit in one of the
ways discussed in this video here not
exactly unlikely or number three it
turns out that luffy's fruit has never
been the rubber fruit after all but
actually a legendary power feared by the
government for example like the sun
wukong fruit something i also made a
video about if you're interested now
since we can't have luffy be
unreasonably stronger than all of his
peers right after wano i think that this
will simply be the first time that we
see it happening and the incredible
potential that comes with it similarly
to how luffy used congress hockey at
marinefords
[Music]
i really think it will only be something
that luffy will actively master towards
the actual climax of the story when he
will inevitably have to face the
cataclysmic powers of blackbeard akainu
the gorosei and imu and i honestly think
that that's a fantastic writing choice
while i can see some people complaining
that it would basically come out of
nowhere as i've laid out for you just
now i think that it has been
foreshadowed and worked towards for
quite a while now it also will not
diminish luffy's previous efforts
against kaido at all i think especially
since cp 0 put an unhonorable end to the
battle anyways and stab luffy in the
back much rather i think it is something
that will showcase luffy's unparalleled
will to win protect his friends and
fulfill his dream in other words the
things necessary to even awaken these
powers in the first place now as
exciting as it is knowing that luffy is
about to get his power up if you really
want to blow your own mind and take it
to the next level this isn't enough on
its own you have to know what it
actually might be there is actually an
absolutely crazy theory about luffy's
close connection to the monkey king sun
wukong that has changed how people see
one piece forever and that's why you
really shouldn't ignore this video
because it's twice as exciting as this
one and in combination will make you
feel like you've really figured out
luffy's true powers also if you've read
the latest chapter you can also check
out my thoughts on that right here